a dramatic turn of events we are just
outside the Supreme Court in the past
few minutes we have heard news that the
court has ruled that Imran Khan's arrest
was in fact illegal and that he must be
released immediately you will recall
just a couple of days those images of
him being taken from another courtroom
picked up by paramilitaries from the
Rangers there and since then he has been
detained only yesterday we were told he
would spend eight days into tension but
now he will be released now inside that
courtroom Imran Khan has told the court
that he was kidnapped and was hit with
sticks he alleges he said I had no idea
what happened in the country after my
arrest we know of course that we have
seen these pitched battles between
protesters supporting Imran Khan and his
party the PTI many deeply aggrieved
about the manner of this arrest they've
always maintained that it is illegal and
those have played out over the past 48
hours in varying degrees of intensity
now Imran Khan has said he he will need
to accept whatever decision is now made
by the high court and the reason that
the high court is significant is that
the Supreme Court yes it has ordered
that Imran Khan is released today but
tomorrow he will appear before the high
court now the high court has previously
ruled that Imran Khan's arrest was legal
so we have potentially a bit of a golf
there and now just behind us we can see
some of the Rangers the very Rangers in
fact that first took Imran Khan arriving
here concern I think about
tension a building here there's really
only a handful of Imran Khan's
supporters Gathering as the news came
from the court there was a kind of brief
Elation obviously there could be some
technicalities we know that there has
been this intense game of legal cat and
mouse Imran Khan accused of corruption
he's facing more than a hundred varying
cases of contempt of court and
Corruption as well the concerning his
supporters is that the military and the
government will find something another
charge to been on him and that he'll be
detained again but tonight at least
Imran Khan is due to be freed
well we will follow this um breaking
news throughout the program throughout
the course of the next 24 hours to see
just what happened since that news came
out Cordelia but you've been on the
streets of Islamabad for the last couple
of days now talk to me about the mood
among his supporters obviously this is
breaking news so not everyone will have
heard about this decision yet but just
give me an idea of what you've been
witnessing over the last couple of days
but we've seen lots of people coming to
Islamabad on the streets during the day
at night as well there's been clashes
with police we've seen protesters
throwing stones police firing tear gas
and I think what's perhaps most
significant in this moment is seeing how
deeply aggrieved his supporters are so
aggrieved in fact that they've been
attacking military installations we've
seen some fires there we've seen people
breaching the entrances as well that has
not happened before those kinds of
things we have not seen in Pakistan the
military is very omnipotent it's
incredibly powerful it's very revered in
much of society to so to see people in
this moment so angry that they're
willing to do that I think is a sign of
how febrile things have got and this set
amongst a really difficult period for
Pakistan on as well it's facing
significant economic woes you know we've
seen massive inflation
and really as well a rise in Terror
attacks the political climate has
pitched uh Khan who has become you know
the comeback King politically Against
The Establishment now he has taken to
the streets he has survived an
assassination attempt that was an
assassination attempt we witnessed
ourselves Sky News was on that container
when he was campaigning and he faced
that attempt on his life he's been
injured from that but he's maintained
his campaigning profile and we've seen
his party try to rally people I think
they saw this as a rallying moment for
the country because people feel there is
just undue charges against him that the
establishment is trying to find any way
to stop him getting what he wants which
is an earlier action and of course to
run this country so I think now Sarah
Jane the stage is set for another
intense battle between him his party and
the government and this military
establishment as well there is clearly a
big disagreement